you ready all right five four three two
one what's up everyone it's chris and
today we're finding a date for suvi and
subi you're gonna try three different
japanese dishes cooked by three single
guys and then you decide who you're
gonna go on a date with just based on
those dishes oh that's a mouthful sound
good okay sounds good and also i think
at least one of them might not be
japanese none of you guys are japanese
right no no
do you think she'll be able to tell yes
maybe it doesn't matter yeah i told them
to make japanese food but we'll see i
grew up in japan also canada us you know
i lived in many countries and cities but
you know i know japanese food the most
what do you look for in a guy to be
honest i don't even know if i know what
kind of guys that i like yet because i
haven't dated with many guys i used to
date more girls this is really new so it
might be like interesting discovery
process for me as well
what do you think an attractive guy
would cook for you you know the cooking
involves like a lot of thinking process
right that's really important why he
chose that dish for me does he play it
nicely or you know the color or those
kind of things are important to me too
attention to detail yeah hi i'm randall
hey i'm eric hey what's up i'm eugene so
how confident do you feel about
destroying the other two guys yo
wow that's a really strong question
right off the bat but i think that my
dish is it's something that i eat every
day actually so i know it tastes really
good eugene how you feeling i'm
extremely tired you guys are like so
prepared like you guys are dressed up
you guys have a game plan bro i like
rolled out of bed i was like
i bet he got takeout don't call me out
like that
[Music]
um i made some instant ramen i mean i'm
i made some ramen but i tried my best to
gourmet so the secret is actually to
separate out your ingredients when you
make it you make your noodles first and
then your soup you don't make it
together or else it gets soggy and then
i added a little bit of sesame oil and
green onion to this for the soup i put
it together man
and then i just brought some pocky
because everybody likes something sweet
after they eat i guess i used to make
like instant ramen a lot when i was in
college when i was like on the struggle
bus i hope she gets from it is like just
make the best of your situation life
gives you instant ramen make that
gourmet you know like fire away
okay
oh wow
this is cute oh my god i feel really
impressed i like the personality already
but i'm a little bit scared to eat this
like it's not a authentic ramen i think
it's something that
friends call me out
so i think
he's not japanese
this choice too actually makes me think
that he's not japanese but he's trying
to present like you know japanese he's
like a little bit like fun personality
you know kid at heart yeah she's pretty
cool he also had chashu but he forgot to
bring it
he might be like somebody like in a
little clumsy kind of
that's cute too right exactly my
attention went to the pocky
so mine is a salmon pan seared so it had
the crispy skin and then afterwards i
glazed it in some teriyaki sauce it's
going to stay on top of a better rice so
the sauce can go onto the rice too to
give it some flavor you have some
veggies so this is going to be on the
side everything's really minimalistic
because that's just the type of person i
am and it's going to be detail-oriented
when it gets presented it's gonna look
like it came straight from a restaurant
because i want that presentation to be
like that fish it could be seen as like
one more elegant type of meat so i want
that to come off too three two one
oh wow okay
this looks so professional wow
he has an eye for aesthetic you know the
color is really nice but it's like
really neat so i think he's like a very
organized person and you know attention
to the detail oh she didn't say a time
to detail he showed up wearing a white
dress shirt and a sweater i think like
it matches his image but probably he's
like japanese american oh so at least i
got the japanese pawn
wow
tastes so good i think he chose really
good fish too what i imagine about him
like pretty neat looking i think we get
along you know like i really like good
quality stuff and i appreciate people
who have the same value as well between
the two which one would you rather date
that's the difficult part because i
think the first person like charming
like fun person she called me more fun
like a second person maybe like a little
more proper i might need to see the
third one yeah i'm just happy right now
she said it tastes good
so i brought some chicken and rice today
that's so boring oh my god
i mean it's
that's like the typical jim bro you know
dinner i brought like a chicken thigh
with honey garlic sauce and soy sauce
and then i made like this japanese side
dish just white rice with a pasteurized
egg and then some soy sauce with the egg
it's like even more protein it's really
authentic to me when i cook i just want
it to taste good it's easy to make and
straightforward
wow
wow
i don't think anybody's from japan i
think you know japanese american but it
doesn't matter right who do you think
made this home maybe he doesn't cook
that much
but he put like a lot of effort into it
there's not much color
you know it's like oh brown like a very
manly guy it's like meat rice yeah no
she's actually pretty good
tastes really warm yes
she should know what this is i don't
know what it is
[Laughter]
so how attractive do you think he is
um
you know like athletic guys it's good
but also like i wanna know the
personality more right i asked him how
he would describe his personality and he
said jim bro yeah that's my that's how i
feel the gym bro so is it going to be
like a gym date
but you know simple is good right no
drama just straight forward yeah
straightforward kind of guy i think
honestly that was what i was going for
she hit on everything i was going for
she's pretty good at that
okay subi who are you going on a date
with
this one you know tastes really good
he's simple and that's nice but i don't
know if i have much common interest
these are actually like hard choices you
know attention to the detail like this
is a broken but he might be really fun
this person right here i think the
visual and then that you know he cares
about quality that really matches with
my personality he might be too proper or
intense then you know i might not be
able to open up do i want to go on a
nice date or like something a little
crazy and fun
i'm actually curious about this person
he might bring the laughter you know
yeah really curious about this person i
wasn't expecting that instant ramen does
the trick i can't believe that worked
all right you ready to meet him yeah
hello
thank you for cooking
yeah but it was really fun do you guys
cook usually or yeah
wow they did really good you know but
that dish that i cooked is something
that i eat every day yeah because i
thought maybe you know you have this
like the protein yeah yeah i hate to
interrupt you right here eric but
unfortunately you didn't win so i'm
gonna have to ask you and randall to
leave okay so
uh yeah yeah just get out of here get
out
you know the drill i'm gonna send you
guys off and you're gonna go on a mini
date and then afterwards we'll check
back in and we'll see if you want to go
on another date after that sound good
that's good cool awesome
do you want more pocky
[Music]
are you guys going on another date how
are you feeling i think it was pretty
fun you know it was unique very unique
we try to build an eiffel tower with the
pillows we did pretty good we did pretty
good
the point um eugene where are you taking
her on another date um
i say that we're pretty tired i would
say we can go back to the couches and
take a nap
that's what they call it now
would you down for a nap yeah of course
yes
all right see you losers
[Music]
you